do you talk to alan at all still or no
um i've we definitely been in contact
just like saying good things um
he texted me on my birthday we're super
good friends and like everything's
really good energy forged in a burning
world
we rise from the ashes to reimagine the
future
this month is a very big month for you
you're launching
future prosperity so first of all what
what is this
so future prosperity is a futurist
lifestyle brand and it's also a
regenerative marketplace
with like pain point essentials that we
use every single day
with no plastic in them because plastic
you know a lot of people don't know but
plastic is actually fossil fuel plastic
pollution
is a huge problem on our planet right
now but it's just not necessarily talked
about
and so much of the direction that i've
wanted to go into is this environmental
space
but one of the blocks that i've had with
it in my mind is like it's such an
intense space to get into
so what type of products are does this
encompass it's little pain points that
we don't usually think about so like
when you go to the drugstore for
instance you pick up a razor you pick up
you know plastic wrap for your leftover
food it's like all these little things
that we don't they're kind of like
mindless right then just go and get them
and throw it away and we go ahead and
throw it away we don't know where they
go um so that was
these are those products currently so we
have um a bundle which is going to be a
kitchen bundle and we have a bathroom
bundle
and what's super super cool about this
specifically is my
favorite part about it is that you
actually save money over time
because these products last so much
longer
they have refills you can go on to
future
prosperity.com and it's live
at the 8th so it's crazy we've been
working on this for
six months so i'm just like i can't
believe it's happening now
what was that initial moment for you
when you became so passionate about this
because i know you have been passionate
about this for a very long time
well i remember reading in a book that
scientists don't even talk about our
kids kids
because they don't see our kids kids
having a future because of what we've
done to this planet and that that every
moment
that moment was that's when it hit me
the hardest because
you know to be a 23 year old and
you know think about being a mom and
being unsure if that's even
if this place is even good to raise a
child like
that's what really motivated me and also
seeing that
you know my generation they're ready to
take responsibility that is really scary
to think about that our kids
kids i mean that they could
not have like a beautiful planet to grow
up in like that is a really scary and
sad thought yeah really scary and it's
real and
like i grew up near the ocean so you
know i've spent many hours being at the
beach being like wow i don't know
if my kids kids or like even two
generations ahead of us are going to be
able to like see this beauty and
that's what i really want for them
changing gears a little bit
i told you already i love the blonde
hair was there a moment that inspired
the hair color change or were you just
like wearing covid wearing quarantine
and
you personally knew i want to say it was
more of an energetic thing like
i i went really really dark about
six months ago and then as i was
just understanding what my voice
was understanding the position that i
wanted to be in in this world
i felt more light it reminds me back
when i was like 17
so i was nervous about that because i'm
like i'm not that person anymore but it
has changed my life
um but it i feel i feel like such a
different person now that that doesn't
that doesn't um stop me from
being this now and then and i love it
i'm really excited it's never matching
yeah your blondes have more fun in your
opinion
um i'm definitely having more fun with
the blonde okay good dancing with the
stars
have you been watching who are you
rooting for
i have not been watching um i recently
saw
val and jenna downstairs in my apartment
building and i was like oh my god and i
like gave them a big hug so
like i keep in contact with a lot of
them and i'm so excited so
like whitney and lizzy they're both
pregnant i was like
i've definitely seen on social media and
you know texted them
congratulations and like i hope
everything's going well with them so
you did come in fourth when you were on
the show if there were ever to be an
all-star season again
would you would you do it i don't know
it's definitely a possibility i mean
what was i love performing like it's my
favorite thing in the world i think it's
like the most exhilarating thing
and it's super addictive so being able
to perform again like that would be
beautiful i mean i love dancing and it
was interesting you know dancing with
the stars it really showed me
the self the self belief that i have now
because of how much it pushed me
physically but not
physically mentally like you you just
didn't have a choice
you talked to alan at all still or no
we've definitely
been in contact just like saying good
things um he texted me on my birthday
last night unless you're just saying
happy birthday i mean
we're super good friends and like
everything's really good energy
so yeah like the best outcome possible i
love that
[Music]
i'll quickly touch base in the warriors
really quickly but it's like
this amazing gated lifestyle and fitness
community where i have like thousands of
girls in it where we all
we do live calls with dietitians and
eating disorder mentees
and i do a live call with them every
friday and
we have challenges workout challenges
but it's so much more than just
that it's for me it's like walking with
these girls through the struggles that
i've personally had so
yeah that's been really fulfilling um
we're bringing on a bunch of other girls
um to become warriors as well so it
gives an opportunity for
you know the girls that are in my field
to be able to like share
how they are their their optimal selves
um
and be teachers because i think we learn
the best when we get to teach
what we've learned where it really goes
into ourselves more
so that's amazing is it hard because i
mean you have been open about
your past struggles is it hard to be so
vulnerable with all these women or do
you find it
empowering in a way it's super
empowering like
there's nothing more empowering than the
truth in my opinion because then it's
like you're taking the power out of
anyone else's hands and saying
i know this is my truth and this is how
i've evolved because
because it's a part of my story and like
whatever is your story is beautiful
that's
the complexity so um having these girls
open up to me about their struggles and
then
not only hearing them but like really
understanding where they're coming from
and then being like
how can i make something for these girls
that i wish
i had at that time when i was 17 and in
the public eye and i didn't know how to
take care of my body
so that's that's the idea behind it and
it's been growing it's so
amazing and it's like the most
fulfilling thing ever
to be able to live with these girls and
just laugh and talk for like an hour
it's like therapy
it's literally like get around a table
on a zoom which is like
how's everyone's hearts and we're all
just like ah and we're like
okay that evolution
like in between teenage and womanhood
and like that really programs who you
become
in your early 20s from what i've
experienced i think you opened up about
like an eating disorder
like how were you able to really pull
yourself out of that like what do you
tell these girls
it was it was my support system it was
my family it was the people around me
and that's literally why i created this
because i was like if it wasn't
for my god sister my godmother um
all of my friends kind of pulling me out
of my you know
delusion being like you can't do that
like you're slowly killing yourself we
love you we care about you like
be honest with us and so having that
and and some people don't have that and
that's why i was like we have to make
something for these girls to have
something to lean back on because i
don't know where i would be without my
support system and like to this day
like they are what keep me grounded and
remind me
what's real and what kind of influence
we can all truly make